it's been described as the worst blow to
wildlife in israel's history
this nature reserve in the north was
once a bird watchers dream
migratory cranes gather here from colder
climates before moving south to africa
but avian flu has turned it into a
graveyard
the scope of the current outbreak in
israel is massive
and we see that it it's not stopping in
the wild animals so it is worrisome and
i must say that with the attention of
the israeli government and other
countries to covet 19 we should not
neglect other public health hazards and
we must tackle
avian influence as well
the cleanup is taking time the area now
off limits to the public for fear of
contagion
at first about two weeks ago when they
discovered the disease about 50 to 100
dead cranes were identified here within
a few days the numbers reached thousands
and today they're about five thousand to
six thousand
israel is taking preemptive measures and
is called hundreds of thousands of
chickens the virus hasn't yet been
contained
and even though we're told the threat of
spreading to humans is low it remains a
possibility that needs to be taken
seriously we fear of the possibility
that the same person will get infected
from human influenza
and from evian influenza and there will
be genetic reassortment and we will have
a new virus that is both
pathogenic
and easily spread among humans that's a
theoretical possibility but we must be
very alert in order to prevent it at a
time when the world is already
struggling to contain mutations of
covert 19 with omicron infections here
expected to double and triple over the
next few weeks
images like this
are only making people more nervous
stephanie decker al-jazeera jerusalem